des jardins éphémères il y en a onze
répartis dans les lieux les plus
fréquentés du centre ville d'orléans
voici celui de la place du martroi le
coeur de la cité où le paysagiste
françois tillier nous alerte sur la
montée des eaux et ses conséquences
dramatiques crois que tout le monde
maintenant a compris les enjeux
climatiques et le fait que les réfugiés
climatiques vont seront de plus en plus
nombreux après c'est bien de faire
quelque chose même si semblerait-il
d'après les scientifiques c'est quand
même un petit peu tard pour la deuxième
édition de ce festival sur l'espace
public
les jardins éphémères explore le futur
il peut être plein d'espoir comme cette
création d'un pépiniériste local baptisé
le jardin d'éden
elle démontre que l'humain peut encore
réellement améliorer le visage des
villes tout particulièrement quand une
filière professionnelle de qualité s'y
attellent le loiret représente une
filière importante de l'horticulture
faut pas oublier que 80% de la
production du loiret est exporté du
département donc c'est nous avons
vraiment des acteurs des artisans de la
diversité végétale dans notre
département
un atout indéniable pour verdir les
villes si chaque citoyen veut bien y
contribuer à l'exemple de cette
compagnie théâtrale qui a créé un espace
dédié aux arbres au pied de la
cathédrale d'orléans un coin de nature
pour soigner l'esprit désormais nous on
est une troupe de théâtre on est
installé au nord du département du
loiret théâtre diminué on est aux siens
et dans ce théâtre à un jardin et bien
le jardin c'est résilient ça absorbe ça
absorbe les crises jusqu'au 1er novembre
vous pourrez déambuler d'une création à
l'autre pour lutter contre la morosité
ambiante et peut être glaner des idées
pour votre futur jardin
là